those who are afflicted with the
darksign lived forever locked in a
constant state of death and revival but
immortality isn't seen as a blessing
here it's labeled the curse and with
good reason
death is replaced by a form of insanity
a state where humanity is lost and the
being becomes Hollow they no longer have
the will to retain their humanity to
maintain their body or their mind
hollowing is a constant process but a
point of no return is reached where
humanity cannot be restored we meet
Oscar of astora just before he reaches
that point of no return I can feel it
coming it's so easy to forget Oscar's
role but meeting him is arguably the
most important thing that happens to you
without him you would still be locked
away he goes to the trouble of finding a
key to your cell but why well there's a
reason thou who art undead art chosen in
thine exodus from the undead asylum
maketh pilgrimage to the land of ancient
Lords when thou ringeth the bell of
awakening the fate of the undead thou
shalt know this is a saying passed down
through Oscar's family but it's more
than just a saying it's clearly a
prophecy it says that the undead who
escapes the asylum to the land of
ancient lords will learn the fate of the
undead something humanity is desperate
to know this prophecy is why oscar is in
the asylum because if he can leave the
asylum
then perhaps he'll be included in the
prophecy and if he's a part of the
prophecy then he may become the one who
is supposed to learn the fate of the
undead but he can't be sure that it's
him there are hundreds of other undead
locked away in the asylum so while he's
on the roof he attempts to let undead
out of their cells hoping to kick-start
the prophecy but there's something else
on the roof the asylum demon guards the
prison have you ever wondered why you
find Oscar dying in a closed cell
there's only one entrance and that's a
hole in the roof he was smashed into
this room by the asylum demon you are a
godsend to come at this moment I wish to
ask something of you Oscar tells you the
prophecy and hollows with the knowledge
that you might be the fated undead to
leave the asylum and he's right you are
but what if Oscar had lived
what if you had both left the asylum
together
please come quickly here's your fate a
pleasure to meet you
sage Frank has spoken to me about you I
am oscar of astora i wish to thank you
for ringing the bell of awakening i am
preparing to leave I will follow sage
France instructions and will seek anor
londo by way of sends fortress
may we each fulfill our respective
purposes I hope that we meet again
somewhere one day if you believe the
prophecy it means that either yourself
or oscar could be the chosen undead both
of you meet the requirements both of you
left the asylum but as time passes it
becomes more clear that you are the
chosen undead not oscar you're the one
who rang the bells and you're the one
who meets the prophecy more strongly
I cannot just stay here I must find my
own purpose
every undead chases a purpose to keep
themselves from hollowing for Oscar it's
different he's searching for a purpose
that's worthy of him and this obsession
is what will spell his tragic end well
how long has it be glad to see you safe
but be careful you must be the same as I
in search of the grave of Sartorius this
forest is the territory of a fierce band
of thieves they assault any and all who
seek the graves what if we were to join
forces how about that if we work
together we may escape the bandits does
that appeal to you very well let us keep
our wits about us one can always do with
another pair of eyes things appear to
have settled I was right to partner with
you I will have a short rest here feel
free to go on ahead while both of you
make it through the world you triumph
before Oscar and succeed where it
matters and finally you make it to the
kiln of the first flame to either
replace the dying God or to finish him
off whatever path you choose oscar
chooses the opposite driven by a need to
be important he opposes either choice
you make whether you finish off the
dying God or leave the first flame to
die so it was you
I had a feeling I shall destroy you
as fate has commanded me foolish pawn of
dark stalker calf and fiendish Dark Lord
perhaps you choose to replace this dying
God and rekindle the age of fire I have
waited for thee foolish slave of the
gods and porn frampt I will kill and
become the true Dark Lord
whichever path you choose oscar opposes
you in his desperation to be included in
fate a search for purpose is all that he
has